segunda jornada de la asamblea general
de las naciones unidas hoy hemos
escuchado al presidente joe biden que ha
comenzado su discurso hablando de los
males que han asolado al mundo entero en
el último año la inflación el aumento de
precios la hambruna mundial la guerra la
pandemia dice que detrás de todo ello
solo hay un hombre culpable vladimir
putin cuyo país pertenece al consejo de
seguridad de naciones unidas un país que
ha invadido otro con una terrible excusa
dice que las amenazas respecto a las
amenazas de putina nucleares dice que
son irresponsables ha dicho también ha
pedido también un aumento de los
miembros permanentes y no permanentes
del consejo de seguridad de naciones
unidas y que se limite el derecho a veto
ha dicho que una amenaza nuclear nunca
es el camino y que no se puede ganar
dice que vladimir putin lo está
utilizando como excusa para atacar
ucrania pero que a él nadie le ha
amenazado el presidente de bailén
también ha hablado de medio ambiente ha
dicho que ha invertido según un último
proyecto de ley trescientos sesenta y
nueve mil millones de dólares en la
lucha en la lucha contra el cambio ha
hablado también de salud se han
distribuido de manera gratuita desde
aquí desde eeuu vacunas contra el cob y
19 más de 216 países ha hablado también
de irán de china ha dicho que no se
busca una guerra nuclear y también ha
pedido libertad de navegación en
referencia a las acciones asertivas de
china en los mares de asia y el pacífico
hablado también de venezuela para la que
ha pedido unas elecciones justas y ha
dicho que no va a permitir que irán
posee un arma nuclear además también ha
recordado a las valientes mujeres
iraníes esta mañana hemos escuchado
también precisamente al líder iraní
quien ha dicho que en un discurso
cargado de dureza contra eeuu lo ha
acusado de desestabilizar oriente medio
y de además apoyar a los grupos
terroristas en esa región respecto al
pacto nuclear del 2015 bien ha dicho que
eeuu pisoteó ese facto y que no aquí y
que habría que dejar claro y crear
algunas garantías que permitan
garantizar que eeuu
el acuerdo hoy va a ser un día muy
emocionante desde el punto de vista de
los discursos porque vamos a escuchar
también a lo largo de la tarde al
presidente ucraniano volodymyr taléns
kirk que dada las circunstancias se
intervendrá en esta asamblea general
número 77 de manera telemática